cette crise de la coved a aussi un
impact important sur les banques
alimentaires j'en parlais à l'instant
avec ma collègue jaune aux dépends de
l'émission l'épicerie qui est avec nous
co animatrice de cette émission depuis
plusieurs années johan bonjour bonjour
christian alors il ya un regroupement de
chefs là qui a décidé de faire quelque
chose de poser un geste très concret
pour venir en aide à ses banques
alimentaires qui manque cruellement de
de denrées par les temps qui courent
ouais c'est une idée de jean françois
archambault qui le grand manitou de la
tablée des chefs la tablée des chefs de
puissants le début de son existence et
quelques années à peine a déjà remis 3
millions de repas des gens dans le
besoin à partir de denrées qui est allé
chercher qui était finalement les restes
des hôtels et des restaurants mais cite
aussi la tablée des chefs
3 trente mille jeunes qui à chaque année
dans les écoles polyvalentes et les
centres jeunesse reçoivent des
formations pee li na et le comme les
écoles étaient fermées jean françois
archambault s'est dit bon qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire la tablée des chefs
comment on pourrait redonner à la
société et en une semaine et demie à
peine y réussit à rallier tous ses
collaborateurs ou presque avec qui
travaille à la tablée des chefs
pour être capable aujourd'hui d'annoncer
qu'ils vont distribuer distribué 800
mille repas pour les 800 mille repas au
cours des prochaines semaines à travers
le québec via une centaine d'organismes
mais c'est surtout à partir des banques
alimentaires qui eux ont grandement
besoin de ça t'aide là et 100 jours on
en paye sur comment commence qu'ils sont
financés mais c'est la force de la table
des chefs c'est que cette armée de
collaborateurs lors ont accepté de
donner on est rendu à 500 tonnes
d'aliments qu'on a récolté de
l'entreprise privée sa vodka scat
bonduelle les hôpitaux de ce monde des
fédérations comme les producteurs de
pommes de terre c'est la saq ou si c'est
courchesne la rose c'est l'association
des restaurateurs enfin la liste est
longue et tout ça ce sont des dents et
on demande à une centaine de chefs qui
ont déjà accepté de cuisine et ses 800
mille repas et pour chaque repas ils
vont recevoir une recette qui est déjà
formaté ça va être du parti chinois du
chili tout le monde va cuisiner
des plats accessible pour tout le monde
et les chefs vont avoir un de leur
parent repas et cet argent leur premier
du gouvernement de centraide des banques
alimentaires de fondation de vigier en
faillite tout un regroupement de gens
qui ont réussi à injecter ce huit cent
mille dollars
quel beau geste quelle belle initiative
ça va donner de l'oxygène à ces banques
alimentaires et aux gens qui en ont bien
besoin en ce moment surtout ceux qui ont
perdu leur emploi et monsieur leubou l'a
dit à faut pas être gêné pour se
présenter
justement dans des banques alimentaires
s'est pas de votre faute ce qui se passe
on est un peu tous victimes de de la
situation on va commencer à vous tenir
informés à l'épicerie parce que c'est le
début d'une initiative de 6 800 mille
repas ce que ça va se poursuivre
peut-être on va suivre la pandémie
bien entendu cette durée là et on va
voir aussi pour que cette distribution
la soie partout qui m'a 800 mais c'est
énorme merci beaucoup merci johan en
remercie de vous y intéresser
merci